-Thank you so much
for watching, everybody.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Guys, it is a big night for NBC.
It is the start of BTS Week
here on "The Tonight Show"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We have something special
for you BTS fans
in a couple minutes.
Also, a huge night for hockey --
if you just watched Game 6
of the Stanley Cup Playoffs,
that means you're either
drunk and happy
or drunk and very angry.
[ Laughter ]
I actually watched the game
through my plastic face shield,
so I feel like
I was really there.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, tonight,
we got to see white guys
brutally attack each other
for two hours,
so it was a pretty good preview
of tomorrow night's debate.
[ Laughter ]
Let's get to some politics.
Well, guys, last night,
"The New York Times"
published a bombshell report
about President Trump's
personal finances.
Yep, somehow "The Times"
got their hands
on Trump's long-hidden
tax records,
and what they found
was not good.
Listen to this.
-The "New York Times" reports
it's obtained two decades' worth
of President Trump's
tax returns.
-"The Times" reports that the
President paid no income taxes
in 10 of the last 15 years.
-That's right --
Trump has not paid income taxes
in 10 of the last 15 years,
although, honestly,
wouldn't it have been
more shocking
if Trump had paid taxes
in those years?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, when the news broke,
Trump was furious.
He was like, "Why did I pay
taxes for those five years?"
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, when it
comes to avoiding taxes,
Trump knows every loophole.
For instance,
on next year's taxes,
he plans on claiming
his coronavirus response
as a total loss.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
What?
Thank you.
It's a clapper.
Some laughs, some claps.
Well, someone close to Trump
must have provided the records.
When asked who might have
a grudge against him,
Trump was like, "Other than
65 tell-all book authors,
no one comes to mind."
[ Laughter ]
So Trump didn't pay any income
taxes for 10 out of 15 years.
Big deal.
I'm sure when Trump did pay
something, it was a lot.
-In 2016, the year Trump
won the White House,
he paid just $750
in income tax.
-$750!
I don't know what he should
have paid,
but it is definitely more than
an Xbox and a half.
[ Laughter ]
$750?!
That's great.
In today's money, Trump
basically paid the equivalent
of a 1993 Toyota Tercel.
[ Laughter ]
Even people who use
the free version of TurboTax
are like,
"That can't be right."
[ Laughter ]
The report also found that,
on top of not paying taxes,
Trump wrote off
a bunch of expenses
that seemed kind of suspicious.
-The paper also accuses
the President
and his companies
of claiming
questionable deductions
on some of those businesses.
More than $109,000
for linens and silverware
and nearly $200,000
for landscaping.
He also wrote off more
than $70,000 in haircuts
when he was on "The Apprentice."
-The crazy part isn't that
he spent $70,000 on his hair --
it's that, clearly,
$70,000 wasn't enough.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Should have went with $150,000.
Landscaping.
The most damaging part
of the report also shows
that Trump might not be
the billionaire expert
businessman he claims to be.
-"The Times" says documents
show the President
reported more than $47 million
in losses in 2018 alone,
and he faces a personal debt
totaling $421 million,
money that could come due
while he is in office
if he's elected
to a second term.
-Wow. This news comes
as a huge shock.
I mean, all this time, I thought
the guy who lost money
running a casino
was a financial wiz.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Trump's got to pay back
$421 million.
In response, college kids
with student loans are like,
"Holy crap! I'm richer
than the president!"
[ Laughter ]
Basically,
this is who Trump says he is,
and this is who he really is.
[ Laughter ]
I guess that, when you owe
that kind of money,
you start doing
desperate things.
Look at what I saw today
on Zillow.
He's selling the White House.
[ Laughter ]
I'll check it out
at an open house.
I'm not sure
if I'm going to buy it.
Since 2000, Trump's reported
over $300 million in losses
just from his golf courses.
Would have been
a better investment
if Trump opened up a RadioShack
inside a Blockbuster
inside a Sears.
[ Laughter ]
It wasn't all bad news
for Trump this weekend.
On Saturday, he officially
named his nominee
to replace the late
Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg
on the Supreme Court.
-It is my honor to nominate
one of our nation's most
brilliant and gifted legal minds
to the Supreme Court.
She is a woman of
unparalleled achievement,
towering intellect,
sterling credentials,
and unyielding loyalty
to the Constitution,
Judge Amy Coney Barrett.
-Whew!
Good Lord, that took forever.
By the time Trump was done
with the introduction,
he had to fill
three more Supreme Court seats.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, the only thing Trump
will drag out longer
are the results of the election.
Of course, the presidential
election is heating up,
and the first debate
is tomorrow night.
It'll be a little different than
debates we've seen in the past.
Watch this.
-Joe Biden and President Trump
are preparing to face off
for the first time.
Now, this debate will be
very different from debates past
due to the coronavirus pandemic.
Biden and Trump
will not shake hands,
there will be
a much smaller audience,
and everyone on hand
will be tested for COVID-19.
-Yep. The debate
is almost here right now.
Biden plans on
throwing Trump off
by walking out in a hat
that says "I.R.S."
[ Laughter ]
Because of COVID,
the candidates
won't start the night
while shaking hands --
well, partly because of COVID,
but mostly 'cause Trump just
doesn't know how to shake hands.
♪♪
-Yeah, I know. Yeah.
-[ Chuckles ]
How you doing there?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, oh, boy.
[ Laughter ]
That's...
Oh, boy...
That's right -- the candidates
won't start the evening
by shaking hands.
Instead, it'll be like
a wedding dance floor,
where Biden casts a line
at Trump and then reels him in.
[ Laughter ]
With the debate
happening tomorrow night,
both Trump and Biden
have been busy
preparing what
they're going to say.
And we actually managed
to get our hands
on some video
of Trump's debate prep.
Check this out.
[ Bird chirps ]
-Alright, the big debate's
tomorrow, and we gotta prep.
We gotta prep.
If I blow this,
there's no telling
how many tens of people will
change their minds about me.
That's why I asked you,
my loyal team of future
tell-all authors,
to come up with questions.
So, hit me.
What do we got?
-Mr. President,
first question --
when will the COVID vaccine
be ready?
-Easy. Tomorrow.
[ Laughter ]
Definitely tomorrow.
It's coming out immediately.
And, look,
it's a very wonderful vaccine.
Tastes great.
Very delicious vaccine --
gonna to be grape probably.
We have our scientists
working around the clock,
mixing [inhales sharply]
the vials and the beakers,
and it's turning the liquid
into different colors.
Just incredible.
Right now,
it's very green and bubbly,
and it unleashes smoke
in the shape of a skull,
so it's looking good.
Next question.
-Mr. President, is it true that,
in 2016 and '17, you paid
$750 in federal income taxes?
-Absolutely false.
-Excellent.
Great, clear answer.
-I paid $350.
-Okay, maybe
let's just skip that.
-Sir, what's your view
on climate change?
-Look, I've said it before.
We love the climate.
The scientists --
they don't even know.
They don't even know.
I watch WKTG --
their meteorologist.
He gets the climate wrong
most every day.
He says, "It's raining."
There's no rain.
He says, "It's sunny,"
but I look at my phone,
and the sun's behind
a little cloud.
Very sad.
It's a tough thing --
the climate.
[ Inhales sharply ]
Very tough. Very tough thing.
-Mr. President, if you win...
-Ah-bah, ah-bah -- when I win.
[ Laughter ]
How about when I win?
-...when you win,
how exactly are
you gonna unite the country?
-I'm going to pass on that one.
-Okay.
How will you ease
racial tension?
-Ooh, big pass.
-Back to your taxes --
-Double-dog pass.
-Well, I think we need
an answer for that.
-I said double-dog,
so, legally, you have to pass.
They said I can have
three passes.
Didn't they say that?
Can we look into that?
Three passes?
-What do you think
of Biden's plan to --
-Look, the thing about --
the thing about Biden,
can I just say
the thing about Biden
is that he's a nasty woman.
[ Laughter ]
He's such a nasty woman.
-Sorry, you said
that about Hillary.
-That's right.
I'm bringing back
all the classics.
No one goes
to a Counting Crows concert
to hear the new stuff, folks.
With me, it's "Mr. Jones"
all night.
By the way, that's where I --
that's where I drop the mic.
-You won't have a mic, sir.
-Well, I'll --
I'll drop this one, then.
[ Clicking, fabric rustling ]
-Not that kind of mic.
[ No audio ]
We can't hear you now, sir.
[ Laughter ]
[ Clicking, fabric rustling ]
-Hello?
-Sir, civil unrest is widespread
across the country.
-Yes, it's very unrestful.
People are very upset.
They're throwing cans of tuna.
Very sad for tuna.
Next?
-Finally, will you accept
the outcome of the election
if you don't win?
-I will absolutely.
Definitely.
[ Clicking, fabric rustling ]
[ No audio ]
-Sir, we can't hear --
[ Laughter ]
Oh, he knows.
[ No audio ]
[ Applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How did we get our hands
on that debate prep?
And, finally,
right before the debate,
Joe Biden just picked up a big
endorsement from Dwayne Johnson.
Check it out.
-I do feel that
Vice President Biden
and Senator Harris
are the best choice
to lead our country,
and I am endorsing them
to become President
and Vice President
of our United States.
-Yeah. Biden said,
"Thanks for endorsing me."
Then Dwayne said,
"Just return the favor in 2024."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile,
Trump was disappointed.
He was like,
"How could you not pick me?
People are always saying
I'm as smart as a rock."
[ Laughter ]
Hang on.
Can we see Dwayne again?
The guy is jacked.
-Whoo!
-If you check the tag
on that shirt,
the size actually says "statue."
[ Laughter ]